this week on quadriga alone in europe
and of the miracle era more and more
European countries are lining up against
Angela Merkel's refugee policies even
Germany's longtime ally France is
turning away and doesn't want to take in
any more refugees than it has already
agreed to several East European
countries are also opposed to maracle's
policies they'd like to shut down the
Balkan route that many refugees use
opposition in Germany is growing too
Merkel's political allies in area the
Christian socialists complain about what
they call a state of lawlessness and the
Chancellor survived this challenge or is
this the end of the miracle era coming
to you from Berlin quad Riga the
international debate your host this week
peter craven yes hello and a very warm
welcome indeed to this latest edition of
quadriga coming to you from the heart of
the German capital and this week it's
all about the German Chancellor Angela
Merkel who she has her back against the
wall many people are saying she's more
isolated than ever before in Germany but
in Europe as well and that's the reason
why the question we're asking this week
is is it the end of the Merkel era and
to address that question I've got three
excellent guests with me in the studio
let me introduce them to you beginning
with Alan Posner a familiar face here on
quadriga
who's a regular commentator for the
Berlin based daily devote Allen says
Merkel isolated Germany in Europe long
before the refugee crisis now she's
paying the bill for her arrogance a warm
welcome also goes to Constanza Stetson
Muller who normally works out of
Washington where she's an expert on
foreign and security policy at the
Brookings Institution think-tank this is
not the end of Merkel Constanza argues
but to win over Germany and its
neighbors she'll have to start making
some big compromises and greetings to to
Anna's ellebra who is another boat with
another Berlin paper the targa Spiegel
although she also writes regularly for
the New York Times and Anna says Angela
Merkel used to stand for a strong middle
ground in German politics now
we're witnessing time of division
interesting stuff now I'd like to begin
with you Anna if I might you I mentioned
already you you write for the New York
Times and your most recent piece was
much quoted much talked about
controversial I might say the end of the
Merkel era no question mark
interestingly what was your message I
didn't make the headline evidently but
how I view it is and I was focusing
first of all on the German side of the
problem that I think we already have
seen the end of an era because Germany
in the past decades has been has seen a
movement a trend what's the middle both
politically and in society and Mecca was
sort of the the epitome of this movement
of being a woman being an Eastern German
in her person everything came together
like all the parts of German society
seemed to grow together and do like this
really cozy huddle thing in the middle
of society and I think this is ended and
Merkel as a symbol
especially the problems of this new
diversion and the forces we see at work
in Germany the mood if the mood has
changed if the mood has become less cozy
if the Germans have fallen out of love
why is it happen what has made that what
has made the atmosphere so sour I think
what I have underestimated myself and
what America maybe has underestimated is
that the fear that is growing out of the
influx of migrants and refugees that we
see currently in Germany and maybe she
like I thought that the middle was
stronger that we would be able to
welcome those people in a different way
and it seemed like that in the last
summer and now we see that lots of parts
in Germany and there there lots of
historic fears this the fear of Islam
that has been at work in Germany before
and these these voices have found one
voice and a new party which is the
eternity before Deutschland and this is
throwing things around in Germany hmm
what do you say Alan I've got the sense
that behind the scenes here in Berlin
more and more people are talking about
the demise of Angela Merkel is a very
real prospect is that the sense that you
get as well I get that sense as a lot of
people are talking about it but I think
you know they don't quite dare to go
there that's why I'm saying behind the
scenes behind the scenes you know but
it's wishful thinking there is no one
who can take a place and that's the
problem I mean what you said is is it's
not quite true is it that Makka
represented the cosy middle ground the
point was there was no alternative to
her then and there is not no one now and
that one reason is that we have a party
in Parliament the so-called Left Party
which refuses to govern which makes it
impossible to form a left-wing
alternative to the Chancellor so every
so she's like a son in the middle and
every other party except for the
left-wing party wants sub coalition with
her that hasn't changed that situation
hasn't changed there is still no
alternative politically in no personal
alternative there is no one there to
take a place that's not something I
think is good it's a fact constant so
yeah I mean my personal response to that
is that for the last 10 years what
Angela Merkel has given Germans
precisely what they wanted two things
I've just remembered that distressingly
I am on record with a 2005 FT op-ed
predicting a maximum of two years rule
for Angela Merkel and it had a title
which I indeed suggested which was dead
woman walking I believe that this was
not taken well by the transferee um but
so that tells you how good my
predictions are but I tend to agree with
Alan and I would also say I'm a sort of
a perhaps of a new point which is that
let's not forget that Angela Merkel both
recognized a tremendous amount of social
change in Germany which was that there
was a large camp in the Christian
Democrats which were sick and tired of
old white men telling them there should
be no gamer
and of course there were a lot of gays
in the Christian Democratic camp and
lesbians for that matter and and and
that where there are a lot of people
saying actually we do need a more
liberal immigration policy and so on and
she recognized this and moved it forward
and got other people to do this as well
I think we ought all to be grateful for
that in I mean this is a you know
there's a swing of a pendulum happening
now with these external pressures forces
coming to bear on Germany but I think we
were very lucky to have had her for as
long as we did because I don't see any
other politician you know having done
achieved quite what she did I also like
Alan think there's no replacement for
her right now so I don't expect to
actually talk about on the ballot you
wanted to come in well what I guess this
is terrible - I agree with you I do it
must be very distressing and the point
about this new party the AFD in your
position to merkel is it isn't
opposition basically although the leader
of this party the FT mrs. Petrie is a
woman it is a leader of the lose it is a
party of the losers of the of the old
white men who feel they're not
represented and it's much it's about
much more than just immigration it's
about then they don't want Germany to
modernize and they're sick and tired of
the whole system and this is the real
danger of this party you know it's not
not not the fact that they mobilized
cinah phobia and so on anti-muslim
feeling that's bad enough but the worst
thing is that they're mobilizing a sort
of general distrust of democracy and
they're being helped by the way by
people in Moscow and so on but that's
another day tional together who want who
want to use them as a lever to destroy
the European Union so you know it's
about much more than immigration I think
the big question is and and that that
makes it hard to make predictions as you
said that are they really just picking
up a mood that has already been there or
is this mood growing and right now we
see the polls for the F D grow every
weekend and they're an hour at 17 I
think in sexsomnia and HUD which is
scary
um but is this just like a glimpse of
the moment or is this something or
they're a new movement are there really
any more people going into a moving
towards that position and I mean as you
said it's older what men we know that
they're the biggest group that is
supporting the IFT if that is the case
and if it's limited to the spectrum the
movement or the the trend is limited but
that makes it hard to to make
predictions really I just want to come
in here because you two were engaging in
sort of an angular Merkel fan club okay
okay typical cozy Angela Merkel fan
already
yeah before the cameras and you know the
fact of the matter is one of the words
that a lot of commentators have been
using here in Germany in the last
several weeks is intended the suggestion
has been that Angela Merkel has not
given people the opportunity to have a
full and proper say on the refugee
crisis and on other matters too that she
gives people she leaves people no voice
and no choice you asked him me I am
asking you sir look this is a
parliamentary democracy the party's over
Parliament were were elected and the
parties that form her coalition were
elected by a margin of some like 60 70
percent they still have over 60 percent
approval ratings I mean did this sort
but this is what I'm getting at this
whole idea that parliamentary democracy
sama doesn't represent the people the
the demonstration saying V as it does
for we are the people as if sort of
there was a silent majority of Bavarian
Ally we heard about this horses a fur
has been as a [ __ ] has been talking
about her period in office her
leadership most recently as a reign of
injustice where's he coming from yeah we
bit there he's not quite wrong I mean
that's quite something different she she
does respond to popular moods Angela
Merkel and she can and she she's good
for some surprises but the fact is at
the present situation where we're not
controlling our borders where asylum
seekers are coming in is not you know
it's not lawful it's in fact in
contradiction to the Constitution he's
right there the question is what to do
about it I would say that a lot of her
competitors are perfectly capable of
self emasculation they don't really need
any help from her I mean that is one of
the tragedies of the current German
political scenery but III also think
frankly that this I mean and you've said
the
said this before this this this
lawlessness talk is is going a bit too
far I mean we can disagree on policy but
to suggest that there is you know that
there are grounds you know for
suggesting that her whole regime is
Italy July illegal I think is just
hysteria I really do and I think it's
irresponsible poor state offered to use
language like this and it and it just
you know it makes him III think it eat
pushes him to you know beyond the pale
of respectable debate it is extremely
cheap to because he's part of the great
coalition yeah he doesn't have an office
but he is the head of one of the three
parties that form this great coalition
so he could have done something hmm it
must be incredibly frustrating for
angular miracle to see him making these
comments and in this way my guess anyway
yeah we'll come back to you in just a
second constants and O's let's look at
some pictures cuz we're talking about
about them rightly or wrongly about the
possible demise of Angela Merkel one
thing we have learnt from her long
career in offices that she has immense
staying power and perhaps just perhaps
she's not quite as isolated as as it
seems Chancellor Merkel's political
career is far from over
she has the support of a number of
European states that back her policy on
refugees Eastern European countries also
realized that the situation would be
much more difficult to resolve without
Merkel in Germany Merkel is still a
political force to be reckoned with our
poll numbers have fallen but they're now
about the same as you'd see for any
other Western politician who'd been in
office for ten years dealing with all
kinds of crises
Andrew Christian Democrats are still the
country's strongest political party lots
of Germans have volunteered their time
to help the refugees even Germany's
opposition parties support miracles
policies in what other country would
that happen so the Chancellor will stay
right where she is at least for the time
being concern so that's another take on
the myth of Merkel she's playing a long
game a long game that she will win do
you buy into that well I would I can't
look into the mind of the Chancellor
what I do know though is that Germany's
constitutional culture and and its
processes are severely disapprove and in
fact the Constitutional Court has made
it very plain that it severely
disapproves of attempt to unhorse the
Chancellor before his or her term is
over and that's mostly why I think this
is not going to happen unless her own
party decides you know to to withdraw
its support and again I don't quite see
that yet because they don't think they
have a viable alternative the I think
the the far larger problem
and seriously anybody anybody who
complains about the weakness of the of
other politicians in Germany shouldn't
blame the chancellor for that yeah I
mean that's really their problem and I
do think that all the parties in Germany
have been exceedingly bad at grooming
our new generations that is one of one
of the weaknesses of both the CDU in the
SPD
that they don't do this well but but
that that said I think our far larger
problem is the lack of support for the
Chancellor's policies in Europe and
there you can blame since the high
command in the policies on here at the
policies on the refugee crisis 80% of
German people were told by reliable
polls belief that she no longer has the
situation under control that's a problem
yeah sure and and and in I mean we saw
in the Munich Security Conference with
the French Prime Minister vows saying
nope you know we're not following you on
this will you know take what we promised
do but not one at one refugee room and
and I and I think that that is that
blame has to be laid at the door of the
transferee because this government I
think is famously inept at
persuading other governments in Europe
that it is in their interest to follow
the Germans I mean there are some
exceptions and the most important one is
the sanctions policy where I think we
can be grateful for strong German
leadership but otherwise I'd say the
record is pretty middling I think much
of the unrest we see within the
Christian Democratic Party is also due
to the special situations that we have
three important federal state elections
coming up in March so it's more than
that there are genuine problems to be
solved there's been an influx of
refugees of 1.1 million or so this year
we've already been told it's likely to
be at least 500,000 next year that's a
major crisis for the job well let's put
it a different way why hasn't the
Chancellor change course why hasn't
Germany change course in the way that
the swedes and the austrians other
nations who have taken in many many
refugees but we have changed chaos
we haven't shut the border that's to one
LaLanne German newspaper wrote this week
Germany has the last open door in the
Western world it's true we haven't set
up fences on the Bavarian border but in
all other respects we and with the help
of the Social Democrats and even the
support of the Green Party we have done
a lot we have declared secure countries
that have been secure countries before
and we will probably do so with three
more and the Greens will probably
support that and it's just one element
and we're working on getting the the
families of the refugees who are already
here to Germany there the policy is much
more restricted now or it will be
whenever this is set into law so there
are many small steps which sum up to a
change of course in American policy and
it's the wider 80% because my problem is
I'm very often surrounded by liberal
rational pragmatic confident
forward-looking journalists like
yourselves and then I'm too and I know
that there are you know there are rabid
crowds of people out there on the
streets and there are 80% of the Germans
who still believe that Angela Merkel
does not have the situation under
control it doesn't fit together that's
where a lot of our discontent on juries
we're also saying that she's got a
problem it's just that I think we
probably all three of us in Rio
so for that you know that you know on
the point of principle yeah she's right
yeah and that and that you can't just
pull up the drawbridge --is and assume
in an interdependent globalized world
that you can that the Germans can trade
with themselves you know and otherwise
you know telephone their friends across
the border I mean that's ludicrous
hmm I'd like to come back to this point
Alan you're an anglo-german journalist
that's what I sometimes termed you in
the past and you will you will of course
be aware of the fact that Margaret
Thatcher used to talk about there is no
alternative Tina it was one of her
slogans for talking talking up her own
leadership I'm troubled by the fact that
again a consensus among you guys that
the somehow a country like Germany with
all its economic and political and
social resources cannot come up with a
decent opposition and they're decent
opposition figure it worries me yeah
right it's me too
what can I say there's this but this has
to do with the with the numbers in in
Parliament it has to do with the fact
that we have a left-wing party they're
the radical left-wing part which is
incapable of governing therefore cannot
form a coalition therefore there is no
left-wing left-right divide and change
of government and the only everyone just
wants to get into bed without an America
right and so this is still the case oh
it was it still the case because there's
no was a well agreeance now possibly
because there really is no alternative
and if you know if 80% of the Germans
say she hasn't got you know that the the
thing under control well of course she
hasn't who does that's mr. Obama have it
under control as mr. Putin have it under
control but Cameron does David now we
don't we this is something that is
beyond controlling something that you
have to manage as it goes on so so if
you know did but this this is this is
one of the things that is rather
worrying the Germans believe that
politics can be controlled and if it
isn't controlled they start to go on the
barricades this is the German hysteria
the people in the rest of Europe are so
worried about because you have to
sometimes live with situations which you
can't control and then deal with them
and just for the record I mean there are
some deeply unimpressive opposition
figures in the rest of Europe you know
starting in the UK I would
yes Constanta is talking about the rest
of Europe let's go to let's go to France
and a very key partner for Germany down
the years let's see what's happening
there at the moment for decades Germany
and France worked together as the
driving force behind European unity
France is concerned about Germany's
economic clout but during the financial
crisis Paris supported Berlin's demands
for drastic austerity measures at the
Mint's summit a year ago Merkel and
French president Francois Hollande
worked together to try to bring peace to
Ukraine but French prime minister Manuel
Valls said recently that his country
will not take in more than the 30,000
refugees it has already promised to help
that appears to be a direct challenge to
Chancellor Merkel's policy of working
toward an equitable distribution of
refugees among EU countries our
relations between France and Germany
cooling off if so what will that mean
for Europe hmm consul you're shaking
your head vehement obey I want to
shaking my head because that was a very
sarcastic rendition of the Marseillaise
which I'm not sure would please our
French friends but you were going to ask
me something a huge challenge to angular
Merkel's authorities the comments from
Monsieur vials at the weekend
stab-in-the-back
one newspaper said oh god that's a sort
of union a German term which you know
has a historical connotation we live in
a trilingual evacuation hazard
recrimination yes and go in any look
anything like that is a you know in
itself a failure of diplomacy yeah if if
French Prime Minister feels it moves him
to get up in Munich and say and by the
way you know forget that that is a
negotiating position no I do take him
very seriously and it means the
transferee has failed egregiously at
pulling him over before and saying don't
do this manual and and he's you know and
that that means the relationship is bad
and obviously that this kind of thing
will spill over into
to other parts of the relationship so
that's you know public embarrassment
that said you know I think we it's not
as though the French had any sort of a
great alternative ideas let's be honest
hmm
I for one am more concerned than URM uh
say because the franco-german tandem has
been at the heart of everything that has
been achieved in Europe in the last
several decades and the tandem suddenly
looks as though it's broken this is what
you've been explaining that has to be a
huge in you know is Europe wobbling as a
construction I think in many ways
historical myths do play into the
current situation in Europe and the
French German axis of course has an
historic connotation there's a lot of
historic romance woven around this axis
and I'm not sure whether this allows us
to have a clear improvement pragmatic
view I think this is a problem of course
it is a problem for anger mallika but
not because it's France that's missing
out and supporting here but because she
doesn't have any alternative allies at
the moment but if she found them if she
found them for example in northern
Europe or in the Netherlands or even
even in Poland if if she if she arrives
at an agreement with with Poland and the
Baltic states then why not form
different coalition's that's just the
future of Europe Allah if European six
definitely definitely this is the future
of Europe the French German tandem is
indeed dead it was it was a myth it has
been a myth for the past ten years one
of its greatest products the euro is
something mixed blessing to tell to say
the least and and and yeah Europe needs
to be put on a stronger foundation and
it can't be the old Empire of
Charlemagne it has to be it has to
include those people who are organizing
themselves in the visa grad group the
Eastern Europeans who by the way our is
Merkel our markets last best hope in the
refugee crisis what they're going to do
with the Visa Card
probably is simply cut off Greece's land
border to the Balkans and that will mean
that virtually no refugees are going to
be arriving here
so mrs. McCord would complain about it
but she'll be you know but you'll be on
her phone saying keep that fence boys
keep that fence because it's people it
would be great for Ellen but you do
admit that Viktor Orban American
schinsky mr. Duda mr. Robert feet so you
know and milosz Yemen are a bit
difficult to work with right now I mean
and I mean I I mean I like you believe
that Germany shouldn't even attempt to
run the show in Europe and that this is
bound to go badly but the reality is
that we have got some very difficult
neighbors out there right now and that's
you know and and I think we have to
acknowledge that and that in some
positions I think we would probably sit
here and say they're actually wrong on
this no I don't think they're wrong on
this with no one's gone
Germany shrinks into the past yeah if
Germany always does deals with Russia
over their heads then what can we expect
it's not always doing deals I've got to
break you up oh god Supriya but I look
up to this at the end of the medical
area yes or no yes it is
Oh in Germany no in Europe yes there you
go I hope we've given you plenty of food
per volt thanks very much for joining us
if you've enjoyed the show as much as I
have then come back next week for now
bye bye